louisville police have released a huge
batch of evidence from an investigation
of the raid
that killed briana taylor back in march
now it raises
brand new questions over why police
targeted her home
in an effort to prosecute her
ex-boyfriend a police lieutenant who
came to the scene after the shooting
told investigators quote
something really bad happened the
material includes more than 250 videos
and more than 4 000 pages of documents
our national correspondent jerica duncan
is following this story
yeah the documents graphic videos and
photographs were released wednesday as
the outcry for justice for briana taylor
continues this video shows a close-up
view of her boyfriend kenneth walker
outside taylor's home after she'd been
shot telling
officers his girlfriend is dead who has
any apartment
nobody my girlfriend is dead
moments later a swat team enters
taylor's apartment
they quickly determine it's a crime
scene we have to be mindful what we say
we're on camera now so
at the center of the case whether a
search warrant for taylor's home was
issued properly police records show the
warrants stemmed from taylor's
communication with ex-boyfriend
jamarcus glover who was the target of a
narcotics investigation
the release includes audiotape of a
jailhouse conversation on the day of the
raid between glover
and a woman identified as the mother of
his child
in it glover says he had not been in
touch with taylor
further calling into question the
justification for the raid
we ain't been no man we ain't been
around each other over two
months in the two months
and the interim police chief is
continuing her investigation into the
deadly raid
it could result in disciplinary actions
or even
firings meanwhile the fbi continues its
investigation
into possible civil rights violations
and an anonymous grand juror is waiting
to find out whether they can speak out
about the grand jury process
gail yeah there's still so many
unanswered questions in this case but i
want to look at that
tape again jerika that you just showed
us with kenneth walker you
when you hear that 9-1-1 call he's in
such anguish such pain he clearly
doesn't know what is happening that
night
so to see him that night with police
going you know my girlfriend's dead
he doesn't know what is happening yeah
he doesn't he really didn't and his
mother actually there's audio of her too
on the scene talking to officers about
what she said her son did which was call
her
and tell her how scared he was because
he didn't know what was going on
it's a heartbreaking story and still a
lot of people believe no justice in that
case at this time
thank you eureka